my name is mario taka i graduated from
the islamic university of madrid
in 2008 i graduated from the faculty of
sharia islamic law um
which basically refers to the base
principle
where by which we derive islamic rulings
um and i did touch upon
um islami or islamic economics which i
later on expanded on
when i graduated here and then that's
where the rabbit hole
or the interest of that rabbit hall
began
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
you're gonna waver you're you're a man
is gonna go up and down based on your
emotions but that has
nothing to do with the reality right you
could feel that way about your marriage
about your job about your friends about
your co-workers about
your entire life and about your entire
existence that doesn't mean you don't
exist
that doesn't mean you you know your
co-workers are bad that doesn't mean
your
your wife is like sneaking off at night
um these are just emotional
uh skeptical moments and there's
something that you really don't have to
pay
much attention to because most likely
it's [ __ ] on uh behind all of it so seek
refuge
in allah increase in quran and uh
may allah allow us to have strong iman
i mean
the symbol at the back marshall it's
reached the limit yeah
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya with the three muslims
we are joined here we got a crypto hash
review in the building
so real quick for our viewers that might
not be familiar with your wonderful work
can you give a quick summary about you
know your uh relationship with the dean
crypto just anything they want to hear
before we go right in
okay
i graduated from the islamic university
of madrid in 2008
uh i returned to the uk to pursue
educating muslims on islam and arabic
um and i did solve since 2009 i thought
to announce it today
um and essentially when i was studying
you know in uni
i graduated from the faculty of sharia
islamic law
and from the things that i i would like
to say i specialized in was
which basically refers to the base
principle about where by which we
derive islamic rulings um
and i did touch upon um
islami or islamic economics which i
later on expanded on when i
graduated here as a self-study not
nothing for more
um and then later on i guess say 2017
um i got involved in cryptocurrencies
uh mainly as a means just accept payment
on my website it wasn't anything
fantastic or any any kind of um
speculative
uh maneuver just literally i want to
expand the
revenues revenue stream i'll avenues
people to pay me
for my um services um and then that's
where the
the the rabbit hole or the interest of
that rabbit hole began
um 2017 and since i've been in that
space since then
learning about it even programming even
just now actually i was just
doing some more programming we've got
something coming up soon inshallah
first of all like i think this podcast
is very important
for this reason and that is
according to what i see i've been muslim
now for 18 years
coming from the background of you know
hustling push and shove
you see that sometimes a lot of muslims
do not
want to push or
they feel that there's a contradiction
between
investing and being successful in dunya
and being
a practicing muslim sheikh maui do you
find that that's
one of the hesitations of muslims when
it comes to
kind of dwelling or you know
entertaining new
avenues of investment in this world what
do you see
yeah so um generally speaking i do find
that uh it's been a while now that the
the dawah has been focused on
the secret of knowledge the taliban
which is great
nothing wrong with her um and it's kind
of
even when i first became muslim i think
it was in the 1990s it was
uh there was not there wasn't really any
emphasis on
the risk or the the attain of the risk
if anything it was seen as a distraction
you know
you get a job and you lose that whole
political images which is generally the
case anyway in
in western land there's not much product
in our time over here unfortunately
um so it was always a case of if you're
going to be doing work or gonna have a
business you're not gonna be a student
college if you're gonna be straight
knowledgeable
get involved in and finance or
income general income and there is some
truth to that like i said in terms of
just being the the nature of our lives
nine to five
you know it's there's no again there's
not much butter kind of time
i mean i've what i found in medina is
that
you could study and you'd have a large
portion
of your day to do something else you
could do something else um
and definitely madina knows a lot of bad
luck at that time but unfortunately
um the race caught up
catches up with all of us and uh people
often find that there's
they don't find it as a balance that's
that's in practical terms they don't
have there's not abundance
but in terms of ideological terms again
some people think it's most
almost almost dirty to talk about making
money
um i even had some um brothers you know
um almost almost
say that they don't want to take extra
money i mean that they
actually said you know i had opportunity
to take let's say
let's say like ten thousand pounds
profit but they said you know i'm just
happy with one
my brother just take the ten man take
the ten why is it
one take the ten so uh yeah i'm saying
this
it's that people think that being nice
and being a good muslim and being a fair
trade means you must
make profit all this kind of it's just
it's just weird it's it's just it's
wrong
anyway the point is uh no
not only what is it i think if you
realistic if you look at it
not only have muslims lost their way
when it comes to our atheida
and our salute in terms of our
mannerisms and our behavior of our
husbands and our wives and our children
we've also lost our way by even our
trade not to java and there's no reason
why you should think otherwise there's
nothing
there's no way you can think of
realistically that yeah you know we've
got a lot of work to do for the tao of
the muslims bringing them back to the
dean but in terms of artichoke
why why would you assume that if if if
broken in in that which is even greater
which is our not our knowledge and of
allah
and his religion then why wouldn't we
equally as broken if not more
in our other avenues of being uh of
dunya
i saw
what's your favorite sahabi or uh tabe
in terms of business skills mashallah
i mean in terms of business skills i
mean i haven't really thought
about in that in that regard usually you
think of them in religious
terms i mean generally speaking it comes
to business i've always always admired
uh
have the option to nullify the contract
and undo the contract as long as they're
not part of the company
um so based on that hadith whenever he
did business
immediately once he concluded he got up
and left just so he made sure that it
was
clear that the business transaction is
finished
it demonstrates how closely woven
his risk was with his with his deen
it wasn't just i'm muslim in the masjid
i'm a muslim on
eid but i'm muslim in everything i do
even business
and it's and it's like an open
demonstration you know i'm going to
conclude business
so i guess in that regard like i said
i've never really thought of this
in that regard but yeah that is
something that always comes to mind when
it comes to being
a businessman
that's a phenomenal intro i say we go
right into uh centralized because
there's centralized finance
go for it all right take the lead
what's your question all right i'll just
relax general difference between
centralized and decentralized
a lot of viewers might not be familiar
with these terms okay
okay so in terms of um
i mean just just just to go back a step
before the whole central and decentral
um finance uh i think people need to
understand what they even mean
now um the problem we have as muslims
especially
in this day and age is that
um we essentially have come
into a space that wasn't ours
now obviously we have detailed
rules and regulations about how to
conduct business in islam
but needless to say we haven't really
been focusing on that as an ummah
for a long while now um so when it came
down to
other nations there's other um who have
definitely excelled at making money
um we are now coming into their space
and we're trying to keep up with what
they are doing
so what muslims have done or are
attempting to do
is to compete in the way that in the way
that they do business
and part of the way that they do
business
is through financing i.e
using other people's money hence what we
have now this concept of islamic
financing
i islamically the way to do business
with other people's money that's how i
like to look at it
um and if you want to go back and look
at islam
and turn the business we need to go back
to our principles
and build our foundation on our uh
principles not on their principles
so when it comes to the issue of finance
itself people said to me oh brother
what's your view on islamic finance
i find it a bit of a troublesome
question because
to me it almost seems as though how can
i do what they do islamically
does that make sense it's like how can i
do how can i copy them
but in a halal way rather than how
should i do things
islamically speaking does that make
sense as a difference
we islamicize things yeah rather than
seeing okay what what is what is the way
in which we do business
as as muslims organic organic islamic
so one of the one one of the
things that we need to focus on is
muslims or one of the one of the
principles of of trade and business as
most
not just business and trade as a muslim
living life
is to live within our means that is one
of the biggest
challenges muslims have today how do you
conduct your business
and even earn money using
the resources that allah has given you
as opposed to
having nothing and then living on board
so i'll give you one example
you guys know you guys know donald trump
in it he must have done a shock
so mr trump he met
his son made it i mean i was talking
about one of the things that his father
mentioned
and he said that um they were going to
the trump towers once and there was
someone who's homeless
outside the the trump towers and and uh
his dad
turned to him i said to him uh
you know that guy has more than me
because he has nothing
and i have less than that well remember
that is
although he has trump towers and he has
always all this you know
investment all of that actually is debt
it's not don't think that he runs his
old business because of the liquid cash
he has
he has gone out to banks and got loans
this is the foundation of business
across the board
they don't function on on capital for
the most part they function on
leverage why use the money i have in a
bank account when i can use someone
else's money i mean i've heard of
something
why don't you use your own money making
you someone else's money
and um this is this is one of the things
that we need to
to find a way out of that mindset
so when it comes to issue of
decentralized finance versus centralized
finance
us what's what what does that even mean
i mean i asked you guys there's three
guys here what does finance mean to you
i don't think i have like a proper
definition for it like if you tell me
finances i just think money
hmm yeah so money management
money management excellent so one of the
ways in which
for example and unfortunately
unfortunately
the whole system is built around
leverage how do you live
with the bank interwoven into your
business model
the idea i mean even even companies as
big as apple
apple has about has on their balance
sheet billions of dollars
on their balance sheet yeah they still
have loans and take out loans
i mean when i first heard that i was
like but why wouldn't i don't get it
why would you do that but because
there's tax purposes while they do so
they benefit benefit through taxes so
they can offset
their inc their their profits with their
their money their borrowed and
there's all sorts of madness the point
is the whole
system is configured
to use riba to have river at the core of
everything we do and as muslims we need
to now find avenues and ways to
engage in business without benefit
and that is actually why i
i i'm a big proponent of bitcoin because
from
in my perspective i see as an avenue
to exist outside of that system as long
as my money's in the bank
i'm still within their system even if i
don't take a loan i'm still within the
system
if i have big if i'm money in bitcoin
for example or on my business on bitcoin
i can conduct my business without ever
touching
their leverage or just touching their
their system
that's just one aspect of it um but
that's that's the
first thing so in terms of answer your
question again about issue of
decentralized or
centralized finance um generally
speaking
both of them have issues islamically
speaking both of them
and for those who are not aware
centralized anything to do with
centralized basically means organized by
a centralized authority so for example
the minister the body of of major
scholars like in saudi arabia
that's a centralized system right as in
we know who
who's in charge we know who who issues
fertile we
is centralized um whereas
the dunya they are decentralized as in
as a whole is decentralized there is no
one
person who is in charge of fit islam
is decentralized there's no one person
in charge of al-islam
that make sense so this is an example of
something which is decentralized as is
not um there's no centralized there's no
single collection of people or one body
that monitors
and and regulates something as opposed
to
something which is open to all
now if you look at islam at the core
islam is decentralized
i didn't think about it the quran it
came down to muhammad
the first thing he did was to
decentralize this quran
spread it to as many people as possible
so that even if
the sahaba was to die it's still there
same thing with the hadith the
the destruction of knowledge become
almost impossible
we have no single example of a piece of
part of history that is so well
documented as that time
in human history because islam was
decentralized
it wasn't saying you're in charge of the
quran
and you're in charge of of hadith and
you
if it wasn't like that everyone
did their part to spread the knowledge
that they had and to and to convey that
in a manner which was decentralized
um and i guess one example today
or kind of like well that's not a good
example so you know so yeah that's
that's that's
i guess my answer to your question it
wasn't exactly answering your question
directly
but um in terms of finance
uh what they refer normally will refer
to as centralized fines i go to the bank
and the bank would finance my project i
give me money to fund my projects
decentralized basically means i can go
to a protocol instead
and do the same thing
a protocol protocol basically is like um
a set of rules
and paradigms and programs that you can
use and interact with
but not a person it's a set of rules by
the way guys let me just push these
lights back because i think my phone is
blowing up a bit
michelle brother gabriel you got a cat
behind you
yeah yeah some lights got some lights
behind me here
i got a cat you said you got a cat i
think my cat was going somewhere yeah
[Music]
you mentioned briefly very briefly that
they both have their cons
right centralized and decentralized so
do you want to quickly go over the pros
and cons
of each so i mean when it comes to
centralized um decentralized finance or
finance as a whole
generally speaking in the crypto space
or non crypto space that basically means
how can you
in a nutshell not always there are some
avenues that are is within the banner of
of d5 they call it but it's not what not
what it says
essentially how do you gain
income so one way is how can you gain a
loan
in your on your crypto you can put up
some collateral and you get some extra
money to spend
so there's one way of actually how you
can get a loan and therefore you pay
interest
and the other element is whereby you can
um
have capital you don't want to loan but
you want to increase
the income on your capital so i've got
bitcoin
sitting there doing nothing we're not
doing nothing it's just doing what
bitcoin does secures your wealth
but i want to not increase that bitcoin
so that therefore rather than being one
now i have 1.1 and 1.2 and so forth
um so d5
some parts of d5 basically would mean
that you provide collateral you provide
um money to the protocol to the system
that system now would take your capital
and lend it out to others and then when
they want to pay their money back
you get a portion or cut off the money
the money earned
now how does it function how do you lend
out money on a decentralized
manner what i normally do is through
over collateralization over
collateralization in a bank they know
where you live
and you have legal documentation that
you sign to make sure that if you don't
pay back you can get it
mine back from some other way on the on
the internet
you don't have such a thing i mean you
can get a loan and you can and you can
be anonymous
so how do they make sure you're going to
pay your money back so
again this is doing over
collateralization so what i means is i
have one bitcoin
but i don't want to sell my bitcoin i
want to keep my bitcoin
so i will deposit a bitcoin into a
protocol
and they will give me fiat they will
give me dollars
but the amount of dollars that they
would give me is actually
less than the value of the bitcoin so
bitcoin right now is that
31 000
usd so if i was to give
deposit one bitcoin into the exchange i
could probably take out ten
thousand dollars as as as a collateral
on as a as a withdrawal of my big
question i still have one bitcoin
but it's locked in their contract
they're gonna give me ten thousand
dollars
now i have to pay back ten thousand
dollars to get back my
thirty seven thirty two thousand dollars
so the question i guess somebody asking
is
why would you even do that you might
just sell ten thousand dollars worth of
bitcoin
and uh rather than go through this whole
issue of
of loans and whatnot taxes i guess you
just like custody the system
is built um around
uh their corruption so if you were to
sell your bitcoin
that essentially is a taxable event that
means you have to pay taxes
on any gains you've made we're gonna
call that gains you made on your bitcoin
and therefore it would cost you more so
you could in theory
lock up 10 bitcoin that's 300 000
and you can take out 200 000
spend it on whatever you want to spend
it on
pay it back over time and still have
your bitcoin
and pay zero attacks that's basically
the reason why you would go on this this
whole
you know as they say in saudi scratching
your left ear with your right hand from
you behind your back is this whole
um so is is that halal sure
no so um any form okay
it's basically it's libra your your
because the thing is to
even if you were to get that loan that
ten thousand pounds when you pay back
pay back more
you pay back more than ten thousand
pascal that's that's where the river
comes into it
now it would be halal
if someone lent you 10 000 pounds
dollars and you used your one bitcoin as
as it was called in arabic was a
guarantee
and then when you pay about ten thousand
pounds you pay back it as it was ten
thousand pounds not extra
then that's perfect hello there's
something wrong with that the only
issues that they've added
onto what they've done added on to it so
um due to that reason it is haram
now if you live in el salvador then you
can just spend your bitcoin because
uh salvador break bitcoin is now money
over there it's now
legal tender so therefore there's no
taxable events
on spending your bitcoin in salvador so
maybe one day in sha allah maybe
misuniverse
if bitcoin gets accepted as currency
and not an asset then there's no need
for this whole
collateralization with your bitcoin
you're going to spend it as money
um which may and we hope sunshine allah
may be
that the ironic by-product of what el
salvador did
because if if once el salvador finally
finalized i mean they have finalized the
law is now legal law but they're going
through the process of
integrating to the economy or not but
once they finish that process
then other countries may be forced to
recognize bitcoin
as currency because they can't just
reject their currency
it's not it's not currency i mean the
whole the whole forex
industry is about trading foreign
exchanges
foreign currencies so if salvador has
bitcoin
as legally their currency then bitcoin
would essentially be
legally speaking a foreign currency
um but i think i think governments want
to resist that because
those they want their pound of flesh
they want to tax you at the end of the
day
that's what they want to do so we'll see
how it plays out we'll see how pays out
we've got
this year the long it's very new news
and there are other countries
are announcing they're going to do the
same as ensembles if at least two three
or four countries do it exactly the same
then i think it'd be very difficult for
other countries to say no it's not
currency is an asset when
you know multiple countries are taking
it as their currency maybe we
will be really weird um but it is what
it is
okay i have a [ __ ] i have a very
important question here
with just because you've you got into
that collateral and all that
but is it like for one to use basically
what's called uh staking features
available in cryptocurrencies like for
example like i think there's you know
some people don't know that there's
other crypto other than bitcoin but for
example like cardano
you can have like um holders take
their tokens which makes you like a node
to help transactions on the network
so basically you get rewarded in tokens
on a percentage basis
is that accepted is that halal i think
it's called staking
yeah so basically again so for those who
who probably are new to all this
um bitcoin is a
decentralized monetary network it's a
network
whereby people can transact value they
can exchange value
in a manner it doesn't require any
authority
um to manage it or to make it happen
the only thing that that regulates and
can and make sure that
things function is mathematics
the whole system of bitcoin works on
mathematical principles
as is programmed inside the source code
of
bitcoin now people think that
think of bitcoin as being nothing as in
what is it just numbers
they say just just numbers um what i
don't realize
is how these numbers came to existence
and it's a bit weird i mean we mean how
these numbers come to existence i mean
even numbers itself is very abstract i
mean has
anyone here held one
or one dollar no no no just one no
yeah because it's abstracted it's an
idea it's it's not a thing
there's one of things but the actual
number one
it's abstract it's an idea even in
mathematics there's actually a debate if
uh going back as far as aristotle and
platon a lot
whether numbers actually exist and it's
it's
these these questions we don't even ask
that kind of thing but yeah they said do
not believe in exist
but yeah anyway so um if bitcoin is not
physical
and i say one two three four a million
to two million bitcoin
what are they well bitcoin
i would say easily is the first time in
the history of mankind
i think it's safe to say the first time
in the history of mankind we've actually
had
scarcity in something that is not
tangible
not physical let me explain to you
so here is um
airpods you know apple airpods and um
i have this you don't have it
now if i was to give it to you
i no longer have it so scarcity exists
in the physics i mean if this occupies
space and
if i move if i move from moving one
space to another space is now somewhere
else
so that's how that's kind of the reason
why we've had money in the first place
is to materialize
the idea of value because value again is
like numbers it doesn't you can't grab
the value
we can perceive value we can perceive
value we can't grab it but if i
manifest that value in a thing
now you can grab it so the way bitcoin
works is that
in order to get these numbers you
actually have to do physical work
you have to do something and you can
even you can even ride a bike you can
even get a bike and ride a bike have the
wheels turn the turbine and generally
just
generate that electricity and use that
electricity to mine bitcoin
and then if you want to mine bitcoin
essentially
that physical exercise you was doing to
mine bitcoin
has now become a bitcoin
now is you know
i've just said that bitcoin comes from
physical activity
uh how do you prove that prove that
prophet prove it because
you can't get bitcoin without it
as you've intrinsically woven the
physical actions of the dunya into this
into this number yeah and that's what my
that's what that was reality why gold
and silver and other
forms of money in the past existed
because they were they were physical
manifestations of work
but to go to a mountain you had to mine
the gold the silver
smelt it separate it clean it fashion it
all that takes work and that is the
value contained within that goal
that's that's how you value it so you've
manifested work into a physical thing of
gold
likewise you can manifest work into
bitcoin but it's the first time you've
ever done that
on something that you can't grab on on
knowledge bitcoin is knowledge
it's actually knowledge it's information
but it's scarce information
all information before bitcoin wasn't
wasn't scarce you could copy and paste
it a million times there's no scarcity
in it or bitcoin was the first time to
do that
but then uh so that's so that's
that's the origin of bitcoin work
so next time someone says to you oh
bitcoin is nothing say no no no
it isn't nothing it's something
as for staking that is something else
that's actually very circular and it's
in what it is so look you mentioned
someone mentioned cardinal for example
okay
how do you get cardinal so let's
let's let's let's do a thought
experiment
we are now going to launch the cardinal
network
from scratch yeah it doesn't exist the
whole net doesn't exist we've got the
code
now we're going to launch the network
babe how do we mine
coins on cardano through staking
great what we're gonna stake
ada which is the name or ticker or
of or ada of cardinal coin okay
great but how do i get these a death if
i don't mind
yet you see how circulated i can't
actually mine
ada sorry sorry i can't mine adams i
stake it and i can't take it unless i
mine it
you see how circle it is it's existence
depends on itself okay
so it's like saying my dad
is my son
is circular because my son can only come
from me and i can only come from my dad
but my dad can i come from me is
circular
so at some stage you're going to have to
aida i have nothing you're making this
sound like the trinity
[Laughter]
you know what you know you know it's
funny you mentioned that because um i
have
used the argument of christians in the
past um when they say to me that
uh why can't god have a son i said you
know what
if god had a son that would mean that
his son
is another copy of himself as all
children
are the same as their parent i mean no
one gives no a dog doesn't give birth to
a cat
a dog gives birth to another dog so if
allah had a son that would mean his son
would be like himself yeah that's fair
enough
we can agree on that but inherently in
that that sun had a beginning
as you know the moment when it didn't
exist and now it exists
said the father's like the son and son
that the father
that means both son and father are
created
because what i'm saying the son had to
begin
and the father is the same as the sun
that means the father has to have a son
and that's why inherently something that
is not created
can't have children or offspring because
that wouldn't
that would necessitate that it also
created
a circle
in order to stake ada you have to
print ada so therefore what's the value
of ada i can tell you the value of
bitcoin is just the work i put into it
that's a lot of work
i've got i'm mining rigs i've got
burning electricity i've got i've got to
do something
what's the value of ada i just printed
it
so essentially the ada at the core of
ayla is
the same as fiat the same as dollars and
and pounds
someone decided to just print off a
certain amount
and this is where you have another
problem an ethical problem
maybe even an islamic problem there was
one guy actually tried to make an
argument against bitcoin
and he said at the point he said oh um
governments should um print money fairly
um and it shouldn't be created by miners
some argument
the problem with printing money is as
soon as you print it
who owns it listen carefully the moment
someone prints money who owns that
because money whoever gets that money
first the question is why did they get
that money
who why why would it be fair that
someone gets to print money and others
don't get to put money you see
inherently in a system is volume
i can just print money because i want to
because
what i can become rich at the expense of
you
which is in contrast to bitcoin
even satoshi himself when he launched
the bitcoin network
he didn't issue himself bitcoin he
minded like anyone else
so the same amount of work that he put
into getting bitcoins he had which is by
the way he's never used
it's same amount of work others put into
it doesn't make sense
so that is that is in essence a fair
system
everyone who gets it or who minds it
deserves because they put the effort
they put the work into it and they got
it
so back to issues taken so in ada the
big contrast between staking systems and
uh bitcoin type system which is called
proof of work so
here's the two we're gonna give teach
the new guys here you're watching we
have
we have something called proof of work
what's the proof
you have mahou what's that what's the
proof you have
that you deserve that thing what's your
proof what's your delay
you've got gold you've got silver
prove you deserve it
uh hold on
can you see me yeah sorry someone called
me i don't know what let me
put my phone my thing on um you're not
disturbed mode
yeah so prove that you you deserve
that thing the proof is that i went to
the mountain
i mined gold out of the mountain i
worked
hard day in day out now i've got my
that's my proof
of my ownership i've earned it that's
the proof of my wages and this is at the
core of
everything in islam think about it name
me a transaction
in islam that is talal except that at
some point
there is proof of work as in even
uh wages when you get paid wages from
the employee
what's your proof i came in nine to five
i did the work i deserve to work
you know anything even if you look at
the contrast what look at the
transactions that are haram
guaranteed income how why why why why
did why did you deserve that book what
because you are rich so
you can see here that we see in islam we
have a contrast those who earn
money because of status
or those who earn money because of work
so when it comes to bitcoin when you
earn bitcoin from money you work for it
and you earn it
or you go out and get a job and then you
go and get paid in bitcoins you've
earned it
stake in on the other hand just because
you're rich
you get more money you see how ethically
from design perspective they're very
different
i'm saying ethically one
is based on islamic foundational
principles
and the other one is very similar to
what you reckon
money but what else you've got money and
because you have money now you're gonna
get more money what does that sound like
to you
whatever whatever it sounds like i mean
it isn't river i explain why it isn't
but fundamentally in principle
it seems though just because you get
money you get more money
[Music]
and those who have more money will
essentially get
more money so we see that in rebar
those who have large amounts of money if
you are allowed to be in the society
money trickles up towards them because
the more they have the more money they
can make and it trickles upwards
in islam it doesn't money trickles down
was through the car those who have lots
of money
they they it's like it's almost like you
have a hole in your bucket
of two or five percent every person
who's had money they have a hole in a
bucket of 25
every year trickles outwards down to the
people at the bottom so money comes
downwards whereas um in this in in libra
it goes upwards
so um in principle like i said this is
just
my ethical argument from design
perspective
in principle staking resembles
but why is it not river okay riba
requires a loan
and in this case header is no loan no
one
is taking money and no one has to pay
you back money on interest
the way it works is that you lock your
fees your money into
a contract and the amount of money you
have in a contract
determines um how many transactions you
can
validate because remember all these
systems about is a monetary system
people make transactions all the time
who regulates and signs off of these
transactions
it's the network does it who who
literally
who's the next person in line to
validate the next block in bitcoin
it's down to work whoever finds the
special number the nonce
they have earned the right to to sign a
transaction and to earn bitcoin
when the staking is based on the amount
of
uh money you stick to the network so the
more money you stake
the more likely you are to get the right
to sign
the transaction so there is in that
respect
some element of work where you are
signing transactions so i'm not gonna
say it's totally devoid of any work
it's just that um the basis of that
is the amount of money you have so
that's in a nutshell
what proof of stake
is which is what either does compared to
proof of work which is what bitcoin does
bitcoins your proof you earn something
is the work you did in it
mathematical work and effort you've done
into it whereas an ada is based on how
much money you
staked so easy yes it is
um the only issue i would i would only
issue i would stay then is that
why would you want to stake
and earn money through uh in an
inferior currency rather than a superior
one
if you supposedly give me choice to say
which one which currency is more fair in
terms of
existence what is more in line with is
i'm in ethics
i'm sure you guys would agree with me
that bitcoin is more in line with
what islam dictates as what is
what is good earnings and earnings as
opposed to that one nothing one is
let's ask ourselves why are people why
are people showing an interest
in ada and stake in and no and you'll
find the same amount of interest
for mining have you ever asked that
question now why not why are people
not interested in reminding bitcoin but
are interested
in staking ada lots of people
it's the same reason why the rich are
happy to give you a loan
i'm not happy to go out and work it's
the same
it's the same principle it's
non-different it's the exact same thing
one you earn money by just having money
and the other
you have to actually do something and
again if i want to be a
bitcoin miner actually someone just
asked me yesterday actually he wants to
mine
bitcoin and i explained to him first you
have to go on get
and buy a mining rig so yeah that that
already means
already we're talking about capital
investment already we haven't started
that we automatic capital investment
then you've got to pay for internet
access which isn't much but yeah
you haven't got internet then you've got
to have
electricity you've got paper electricity
uh and then we did the maps and worked
out if you buy
an s n s 17 and minor which is like a
mining rig which costs about i think
seven thousand dollars it will take you
about a year
to make back your money on your
investment and then after that year
all the money you're making is profit
obviously because you paid for your
initial
capital so you can see here already
it's very much in line with actual
tejada
go out make effort do the hard craft
and inshallah that is
whereas aida just go to coinbase go to
finance buy some ada transfer to another
contract stake it
and then there you go i've made money
you see difference the difference is
ethically speaking
one is through work and other one is not
through work necessarily
so that's that's that's two things but
it's not really about by the way
it's just um ribba they're always the
rebar
on crypto but that's not one way so
that's proof of stake
as well as to the protocol so that's
your ethereum
at some point when it does move to proof
of stake at the moment ethereum is proof
of work so ethereum is a funny one
because theorem used to be proof of work
where you have to do work
and that's moving to private state so
even ethereum exists right now came
through work
and now they're going to transition that
those coins that actually works my work
into this whole statement thing
um but in ironically
although ethereum is proof of work it
also had what's called a pre-mine
a pre-mine basically means the coins
that the
developers or the founders issued
themselves
before they even launched the network
that's called a pre-miner and it's
another one of red flags
of what is a scammy kind of system coin
that basically enriches those who made
it or a fair coin
that wants to launch a network free to
everyone to use
bitcoin had no free and they had no
pre-mine anyone who has bitcoin
earned it was ethereum and this one
might shock you guys sixty percent
sixty percent of all ethereum coins that
have ever that exists right now
came from that pre-mine
did you guys know that one no so the
vitalik gluterin
is and other developers they have to
this day
the majority of all ethereum exists
so essentially if we use ethereum and it
becomes
a current it becomes the system that is
preferred and it gets increased in value
who's really becoming benefited from
that me and you or
them
so anyway so that's so yeah but it would
say this so
those are those coins are uh proof of
stake so ethereum one of them
a there's another one um trades there's
something another one
um polka dot is another one these are
all protocols
that exist um
on proof of stake then you have those
are proof of work like bitcoin
and and litecoins and other kinds of
that um
but then you have staking which is not
like this
it was taken is a very big term
some of that term refers to what i just
spent a whole half an hour explained to
you
another type of staking refers to
literally alone it is literally almost
like a loan
um so for example have you guys heard of
a system called crypto.com
so they have like a a debit card they
can you can put
you can put money on it and you can
spend it but it's like a crypto debit
card
so then you can stake money on their
network
and earn money on your stake but that is
one hundred percent about
because with that mistake that you've
given them they're using that to go and
give loans to other people
[Music]
and when they earn interest and loans
they give you a proportion of that loan
but the thing is they call it staking as
well you see what staking is
is a bit of a bit of a um
it's a it's a weird one because it it
refers to something it's an overarching
term yeah
yeah and one last example of steak in
which sometimes people use a steak
it's not really steaking but it is kind
of staking
and that is providing liquidity
to systems to provide to perform a
certain task
so have you guys heard of something
called an automatic market maker
okay so if i want to go i want if i have
ethereum
and i want to exchange the ethereum for
let's say mana which is from
decentraland so i have ethereum
i want to sell the ethereum and get back
mana
i can just go to finance deposit my
theme on binance
go and press sell and then buy and
whatever and get my mana and then i can
control the manager
that's through a centralized system
meaning that someone
owns a system ie cz for violence or not
but there's something called uh a
decentralized exchange or dex and
essentially what is
that it's not no one owns the system
just it's just a contract on ethereum
and the contract itself that does the
swap so you
send your money to the contract and the
contract gives you back mana
so it's not a person no one owns it it's
just a contract or network you can
launch a contract
and anyone can just use the contract i
can't control you i can't stop you
you could be a criminal you could be
there you could be anyone you can use it
i can't stop you now if i
send ethereum to that contract well
where does the manner come from
it comes from people like me and you who
want to earn some money on our ethereum
and our mana
we provide liquidity so we deposit our
ethereum
and our mana both equal share into the
contracts
and we leave it in there me and
thousands of other people do it
now if you want to go on and sell your
ethereum and get back mana
that contract will just absorb your
ethereum and give you some of that mana
and take a small fee
that small fee some of it will go to you
because you provide the liquidity
so that essentially is if you want if
you wanted to draw a paradox it's almost
like
um an extra uh currency exchange
the only outside you've got on mecca
i've got outside he says guys
you give them your pounds and then you
get reals all right yeah
so imagine you imagine you went to the
monday they said look i wanna i wanna
make some money here's
a bag of money with different currencies
you can use it to do your tj
just give me some a cup of the of the
stuff
of the exchange so that's providing
liquidity
some may call it staking it isn't really
staking but somebody call is taking
but it looks like they can in a sense
that you're giving money to someone
and you're getting you still have your
money but you're getting back profit
uh as a result the only difference in
this case is
imagine i gave 10 ethereum and 10 mana
when i take my money out i might get 11
ethereum and nine mana
because the value of mana and ethereum
differs
and your stake will always have to be
equal in value
so if the value of mana goes up you have
something you have to rebalance your
stake it makes sense so you might end up
losing more or less so it's same thing
same kind of thing in terms of
so that's that that is halal that is
basically
like um you're doing business with them
you're doing business with the con
with the contracts and the reason one of
the reasons why there is halan
is because you could also lose money
because you're providing value and that
values changes mana goes up the theorem
goes down
and you're getting like a certain
different one different amount different
amount
so there is there is risk of loss in
that transaction not all business
and that's that's essentially what makes
it what it is that was a very very very
very very long one so i know i'm sorry
that's a lot
it was good oh i know i know the next
one is definitely you know it deserves
its own episode
but for the sake of time you know just
for a brief introduction
what are markets so what are you know
bull markets bear markets
how do those work what are we currently
in because a lot of people invested in
bitcoin with the hype
now it's not doing you know so well and
they're like what happened to my money
yeah so this is why i'm always telling
people and i think especially for you
guys when you speak to the shabab
the ute when you speak to the youth you
should tell them
um that bitcoin shouldn't be treated
like
like an asset to be traded so
let me be a scenario here
you're living in bangladesh
and you have bangladeshi duckers now you
know
the currency bangladesh isn't that great
and the value of it
might go up might go down you might you
might go down a lot you like up in
lebanon lebanon
they lost more than 50 in a day they
just gone off that obvious purchasing
power
so some countries have some you know
it's not great
so what some people may do especially
especially the rich
those have money what they will do is
they'll keep their money in dollars
now they won't say i'm trading dollars
they'll just get money in dollars
because it's more
uh stable it's more what they want
and they trust it more okay
um likewise yeah so
now now we come to issue of of our
current money
we have fiat whether it be dollars
pounds or ringgits ringgits those
in in malaysia so you have those
those of us have our fiat you have a
choice
you keep your wealth in a currency
that we all know with
sovereignty and no ambiguity that is
losing value every year
every single year it's losing value
and especially now we've covered the
amount of value it's gonna be losing
it's only going to grow even more than
was before we already know this
so where would you park your capital to
keep it safe
would you just leave it in the fiat and
say i'll go down with the ship
or you're going to jump ship and put
your money into something which is
better than what it is before now no
doubt the strongest currency today
in this kind of fiat currency in this
world is the dollar no one denies that
but we also know that
40 percent that's carefully 40 percent
of all the dollars i've ever been
printed
in the history of dollars was printed
last year
so if you want if you if you if you're
buying bitcoin because you want to get
more dollars
then i would say what's wrong with your
brother what is wrong with you why
why do you want dollars
it's about changing your mindset it's
not about thinking oh bitcoins make me
rich
actually no bitcoins could not make you
poor think of it this way
this is this way to start thinking where
can i allocate my capital
to that number one i can evade uh
uh um avoid the what's going to come
which all will agree is going to come
number two you have full control over it
no one can take it from you no one can
steal it from you
you could transact to whoever you want i
can send
all of you guys here i can send you
bitcoin right now i've done it before we
had i had a podcast with freshly
grounded
and i sent him bitcoin during the
podcast
he says i said that i'm doing bitcoin
can you do the ophea can i just send you
money like that about you
you'll take your house and then they'll
ask you oh where's this coming from and
why isn't it
malaysia or well canada all this
question and whatnot
so what i'm saying that is the shabbat
they need to
educate themselves as to why they need
bitcoin
before they start thinking about how i
want to make this money right that might
think about this education why do you
need bitcoin
and the thing is if you understand
the virtue of bitcoin when the price of
bitcoin
in relation to the dollars goes down
your mindset will change
rather than thinking oh i'm losing
dollars
you start thinking to yourself oh wait
i've got a discount i can get cheap
bitcoin
you see different there's difference one
person sees opportunity
one person sees loss and that
opportunity and that loss
comes purely from his ideology
one person sees bitcoin and there's just
a tradable thing you get in and out and
then you
dash to the side another person sees
bitcoin
sees bitcoin as is as a safe haven as
something that's going to be
the future and he wants to get as much
as he can
of that future so i mean
today any any all anyone just about just
go if they're really that worried
go and go look at the price of bitcoin
since 2012. it's
we have not seen anything it hasn't done
before
i mean i've been in space in 2017 i've
seen bitcoin the
goal round from 20 000 down to three
this is nothing
this is what's happening now is nothing
that's why us us old
us um old school guys we like laugh when
he goes down like yeah this is this is
this is great and all newbies like oh my
gosh
what's going on
i'm like sell what you should be buying
brother what are you talking about
if you're serious about your future you
should be praying
not suddenly but again not financial
advice
it's entirely up to you but that's the
way i see it
as for the other question about the alt
coins
that's another question because no one
buys an altcoin for the future if you
only buy autocorn just to make money
it has no function ethereum cardano doge
be honest with you no one really wants
cardano or doji the only one to get the
gains that they expect from it
whereas bitcoin there are millions of
people who want bitcoin
they don't care if it's going up the
credit's got that they want bitcoin
because they realize that bitcoin is the
future that's the major difference
between bitcoin
and there's other coins remember that
one
and what's my proof with whatever
bitcoin i mean look what happened now
if other coins meant anything to anyone
they'll be going up even our bitcoins
are going down remember that
listen carefully if any coin meant
anything to anyone
they will be going up whilst bitcoin is
still going down
but notice whenever bitcoin goes down
everyone goes down
because it actually reveals the secret
in the market
and the secret is no one really wants
those coins
that's why they're called [ __ ] coins
people say that
because no one no one wants those coins
and when things go down i think when
things get when the market gets when the
market gets really heated
and people get scared they rush to
safety what does that mean
selling your your coins and going back
to bitcoin or even dollars but they
don't not
really want those other coins remember
that
so uh as the issue of bear marketable
market doesn't know what brother
mentioned
a bear market it's just a term um the
term
bull market comes in the way that bulls
attack they attack with their head going
this way they flip you into the sky so
bulls push the price
up whereas bears they attack with their
claws so they strike you down
so beers push the price down
so whenever if someone if someone
expects the market market to go down
they're called beers
and someone expects the market to go up
they're called bulls
if there's more bulls than our beers the
price goes up
if they're more beers than they are
bulls the price goes down
so a bull market is a market where the
bulls are in control
and the beer market is a market where
the bears are in control
and they're selling it so chef
from your from your certified technical
analysis which would not be financial
advice just
quick disclaimer would you say that
there's a there's a bull market coming
see um again
for those who i don't i'm sure what i've
said is probably a lot of
without anyone who's really new to this
space but um
the market moves in cycles of four years
and there's a reason for that
due to what's called the harvard or the
bitcoin harvard
the amount of bitcoins issued into the
market halves
every four years when the halves the
supply
or the amount of bitcoins coming into
the market is cut
whilst the demand is technically the
same and anyone knows about markets we
have supply and demand if there's more
people wanting
and not only not many supply they're
available the prices
get speeded up we've seen that right now
with our goods and when we go to
shopping
things in the shop much in this in
supermarkets are going up because
the demand is there but supply isn't it
whatever it needs to be anyway um so
every four years the supply is cut and
then because of that
eventually the price of the bitcoin
moves up to match the supply and demand
so you have this motorcycle breaking
goes up and it stabilizes
and then next four years it goes up more
and it stabilizes and so
forth and that's why i'm saying to you
about the other coins
don't matter and because those other
coins only do well
when bitcoin does well if bitcoin is
doing sideways or going down even they
all go
they all crack the bed all of them
though
even ethereum everyone has ethereum did
you know
that ethereum lost about
eighty-five percent of its value
in bitcoin value not even a dollar value
in bitcoin value during the
the previous bear market that means
literally if you held on to bitcoin
some so imagine you had one bitcoin yes
there's two guys
one guys got one bitcoin another guy has
got one bitcoins worth of ethereum
that means that by the end of the bear
market the first guy still got one
bitcoin
but the second guy now has 0.1 bitcoin
so he's lost 0.9 of his bitcoin is lost
because because ethereum is doing it's
the ethereum's ethereum but
compared to bitcoin people want bitcoin
that's just reality
um until the day
when another coin first acting
independent of bitcoin
they're all rubbish and
ethnically speaking i think that's that
that's actually one of the one of the
things i think
you know you guys probably heard someone
called michael
he's launched he's using his website
called hope.com
and he made that basically website about
teaching about bitcoin
and it's very it's very nice sentiment
because bitcoin is literally hope
if you compare a person who who likes
bitcoin
a person who likes gold they have two
different mindsets two different
mentalities
a person who likes bitcoin is optimistic
of the future he wants
good for the future he's looking at
something a brighter future where the
world would be better
it looks like he likes gold they tend to
be a person who is very pessimistic
you know the world can go to they're
gonna be a crash he's gonna everyone's
gonna die
i'm gonna return back to um swords and
balls and arrows again
so it's very different view mindset is
very different
bitcoin is optimism it's hope that the
future is going to be better because
it was launched fairly it's mined fairly
and it's distributed fairly as opposed
to the as opposed to the other
so in terms of the bull market bear
market is there going to be a bull
market
so right now we had the half million
last year
may it was so now it's been one year
generally speaking due to the two
previous bull markets
these markets uh markets usually last
about a year and a half
so if the if history is uh
a measure of anything which is never
usually uh proof of anything but if
if the now's an act like he has before
we've got another six to eight months
left
uh in the bull market um so just you
know
i would say to people i'll say to people
if so if you're interested in the future
stick to dca
and dc basically dollar cost averaging
which basically means setting up a
schedule
i can i make for example i earn two
thousand pounds a month
i spend about one thousand five hundred
a month on living
i mean i may spend 250 on gadgets and
whatnot
i got 250 left every month so that 250
that i'm not going to spend on anything
special i'm going to put that aside of
my savings
into bitcoin every month every month 250
every month 250 regardless bringing
bitcoin goes up
bitcoin goes down to 50 to 50 to 50.
if you keep that up for at least four to
five years insha'allah i guarantee well
i can't guarantee anything but
if history is anything you shouldn't be
better off than you are
now um as opposed to saving it in pounds
you're losing about
five to ten percent a year that's up to
you
but um but don't don't try and time the
market don't try and gamble the market
don't try and get in here and get
stick to your schedule the fifth of
every month
to 50 or 100 or 50 quid whatever you can
afford
that's expand you don't don't need to
use it for next five years
just do that and i i i would
i could even say and alamos best
uh if you're in like a country like
england or american you can eat and you
can afford about 250 a month
or maybe 300 a month probably in five
years time probably
probably be able to be able to buy a
house outright in maybe malaysia or
or something like that easily easily
it's not difficult um so yeah
change your perception tame change your
time preference
don't chase the quick the quick uh
turnover there's no such thing as easy
money money takes time
and hard work so yeah that's that's my
rental volume
yeah where can people find more of you
if they want to
see some videos so yeah we've got a
website
called cryptohashreview.com um
uh i haven't updated it recently so
there's a lot of things on there on on
our youtube channel
on the website yet but yeah most of our
a lot of our videos that are there
uh on youtube or you know usually we
have like over 130 videos
on crypto and bitcoin not really crypto
but bitcoin
um how it works how it functions you
know everything
and more importantly it's on those who
are interested about the halal
we have we have literally we have about
54 videos
established in the last case of bitcoin
so if anyone wants to say that bitcoins
haram
go for those videos and then
please refute me i beg
i love my witness i want someone to come
and actually answer
the the videos i have because i've
challenged in a nice way no no no not an
arrogant nice i've approached so many
people who said it's habane
look let's discuss this and they've all
refused
i'm waiting for someone to actually just
answer the question because
the reason i say reason says because so
many people have been put off
by these tower that is haram and they
have not no one's brought any evidence
and this and in islam you know
everything is hella until you bring
evidence
so where's the evidence so i want i want
someone to go to my videos
and pick everything find fault and bring
it to me a shout out so you can all poke
benefit
i'll have to bend it myself
there you go fad
that's the one brother at the bottom you
haven't said anything rob the whole time
no but this is good stuff like i have a
question i actually have multiple
questions but
okay all right so one question that i
have because you were kind of talking
about that uh bitcoin
if you try to take out bitcoin then it's
it's taxable
they're gonna tax you for it now you
said they have the thing where you can
move it over and you have like i think
it was uh like
the debit card or credit card or
something like that most of
your coins yeah your crypto into
something that you could use now
how would someone actually get this
money out
without being taxed besides what you
mentioned
of using it as a financial type thing
in uh el salvador very very good
question very good question
so um and this one shall i think
uh from romani will hopefully appreciate
it as well
um so basically what i've often said to
people
is that i think this is
and i would love for this to manifest in
a real way
i think bitcoin not only is avenue an
opportunity for us to escape
ripa what is also a big
avenue for us to make hijab listen
carefully
if you're in canada or you're in uk
or you're in france and you just and you
just wish you could make hijab
dcaa bitcoin dollar cost average your
bitcoin
spend at least four years saving
whatever you can in bitcoin
every month every two weeks whatever buy
your bitcoin don't don't look at the
price don't follow this don't chase this
scam here not a scam coin there just
just dca bitcoin and then at the end of
your fourth to five
fourth or fifth year i think you should
have enough money
to just leave the land you are you can
buy in turkey you can buy a property
for about wait if you bought something
that was about 250
000 uh dollars not only you have a
property you have passport
that that okay that completes your hijab
in that regards
or you can just buy a small flat eight
eighty thousand dollars you can buy a
flat it's yours
you wanna get the longest city you won't
get citizenship but you can still
live there yeah and with the remaining
money you have there you could in theory
if you manage your fund your funds
properly
you could actually live off the rest of
your money on bitcoin for
over over over a decade i'm sure you're
not going to do that we're gonna do
business or not but i'm saying you could
still
set up yourself and your family outside
your country
and that actually does solve your issue
of taxes because you're no longer
in your taxable environment for example
if you're in malaysia for example
malaysia doesn't tax crypto
there's no tax on bitcoin in malaysia
again there's no tax on income from
abroad in malaysia or for example
in uh in in turkey i mean if you left
your country
you can find avenues to avoid and or
even reduce your taxes um to a larger
degree
so what i'd suggest is not to think
about how can i get lots of money
and buy a nice house in in london
forget london brother this is your
ticket
your ticket to live with the muslims
i mean you could even go to dubai dubai
is one of the easiest places to go to
and it's proud to take it tax free you
go to bahrain
open the business in bahrain and that's
it you can stay there indefinitely
you go to egypt there's so many places
you could go but if you have a good
word of cash in bitcoin i am telling you
all that's left you to do
is book your flights and stay masala
because no one can stop you from going
where you need to go
you have to worry about transferring
from one bank account in one country
you literally just go with the money on
your phone
that's it it's gone so it literally
hated the money okay so if if i were to
go
to malaysia
and let's say i had uh figuratively
speaking
fifty thousand dollars in bitcoin
i could take out that fifty thousand
dollars without any taxation
yeah yeah i mean are you american i know
you're canadian i'm in america right
now yeah why are you american american
yes
okay then you got problems
[Applause]
all right bro that's what i'm trying to
ask
come on i i know how to read
is because america is the only country
in the world that taxes you right
wherever you are
so even if you lived all your life in
australia or malaysia or uae you still
get taxed
the only way to avoid that is to
renounce your citizenship
i'm about to renounce it bro
but the thing is um i mean i'm not gonna
i'm not saying
you must do anything but i'm saying that
the only real the only way you can
feasibly do
maybe make such a step is if you have
the capital
to keep you going where you need to go
you can't go to another country as a
poor manager i'm going to pronounce it
you're going to be you can be it's going
to be stuck you have to have a plan
but a major like like what those chef
the whole this whole discussion was that
many muslims
they stigmatize the wealth and what
we're trying to say here is that wealth
is a ticket
to ibadah how can you worship allah
ma'a at least openly
one of the ways to do that is of man if
you're poor
and living in london if you're poor and
living in new york if you're poor
and living in toronto you are finished
there's nothing you can do about it
you're stuck
if you have money you have options
that's one people need to equate money
is options
money is opportunity money money is what
you want to do
money allows you to manifest what you
want i want to
leave the united states how do i leave
the united states will man with one name
primarily not denying that one i always
help i'm saying that
money is a means to manifest your iran
manifest what you want so once you have
that money then we could talk about
avenues
where you could go how to imagine when i
was a citizenship how to get other
citizenships
these things are easy these things are
easy to do but they're not even on the
table
without the man it's not an option you
can't talk about it about the man
so i'm saying that bitcoin is your
hedgehog
if you if if the shabbat about that
change their mindset away from making a
quick buck
you're not saying i want to enact this
ibadah
how can i do so i'm going to use bitcoin
as my avenue
save up little by little learn about the
space maybe even
maybe even make a business on bitcoin
maybe online business online teaching
get
paid in bitcoin and then when i'm ready
i go and the thing is because you've
built your business
on bitcoin that means your business goes
wherever you go
because bitcoin is everywhere you have
to change anything you just continue
rob you're on the plane leaving and he's
still earning call us
so back to your spending how do you
spend your bitcoin then yeah
if you if you want if you wanted to go
with the full whack
and live on bitcoin then you will have
to pay um taxes
while you're spending in it but the
thing is if you don't spend
living expenses you want you're not
gonna be making lots of money i mean you
only
you only pay taxes on the profit you
make so if you're living
if you're spending about twenty thousand
thirty thousand a year
on living expenses how much of that
money you're spending on living expenses
exactly profit
maybe a quarter i'd say a third of that
that's ten thousand pounds
profit so in my country and you
london you have a threshold of about 12
000 pounds
of non-taxable profit if you make profit
less than that
non-taxable so if that's your threshold
then even if you're making
even if you're spending your bitcoin and
you're making profit
it's not taxable because it's not about
the threshold you have to spend an
obscene amount of money
to make that kind of profit does that
make sense
so it's not a big deal yeah so it's not
a big deal
if you're living within your means
you're you're living with zoho you're
doing something
for four to five years of your preparing
to make hdr you live in a
zahid life you're not getting a lavish
iphone every year
you're not buying a new tesla every
month you
live in a normal life of a soviet
you know having suburb you put your
money you can
trying to build your business build you
what not build your future and when
you're ready to launch brother
you launch like this one here your
launch brother is the thing here
is that is that rocket no that's not
cool
no that's not come rocky bro no brother
no you know that coin bro
[Laughter]
so yeah so that's that's that's that's i
think what this should
be focusing on building a future with a
real
established business model um saving
their money
correctly and don't work don't worry
about these momentary movements from
bitcoin
up and down probably you'll be surprised
i'm telling you by september time you'll
be like oh brother i remember this
month's got big become the 30 000. now
is that blah blah blah just me bitcoin
moves
and you don't you know if you don't ever
expect it
all right cool guys very cool
if you guys made it this far comment
down below hashtag bring chef
back because we definitely need him back
for part two we're getting a little bit
more into
into finance into cryptos for your time
until next time thank you all for tuning
in may allah bless you all salaam
alaikum
first and foremost the prophet salallahu
salaam he said that
basically when a group of companions
came to him and asked you know we're
dealing with these horrible
doubts you know these doubts that if we
believe them they would lead to kufur
horrible doubts and the prophet
salallahu he said that this is good news
this is good news and obviously it's
very it sounds
upsy moronic how is you know big doubts
in faith
good news in the process he said it's a
sign of high iman and think about it
if you have catastrophic life-changing
doubts
about your religion it can't be anything
other than a sign that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm
um